[Música]
islandia es uno de los países más
aislados del mundo la costa más cercana
a islandia es la de escocia y está a mil
233 kilómetros de distancia
[Música]
sin embargo cada año lo visitan cerca de
23 millones de turistas es decir más de
6 veces su población hace 13 años
sufrieron una crisis que devastó el
sistema financiero pero ahora vuelven a
ser uno de los países más ricos del
mundo y diréis pero como salieron de esa
crisis y cómo es posible que sean tan
ricos que producen en este país para
tener tanto dinero pues en este vídeo te
lo vamos a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
islandia es un país tan pequeño y sobre
todo tan aislado del mundo que hasta
tienen una app una especie de tender
para ligar en los bares y asegurarse de
que la persona con la que están
flirteando no es un familiar lejano
[Música]
habéis oído bien este país es una isla
que está al noroeste de europa en el que
literalmente puedes nadar entre dos
placas tectónicas y que tiene poco más
de 350.000 habitantes para que os hagáis
una idea eso es menos población que una
ciudad como murcia islandia además está
alimentada prácticamente en su totalidad
por energías renovables son conocidos
por sus volcanes o por la música de
björk y la verdad es que este país tiene
muchísimas peculiaridades por ejemplo no
existe un mcdonald's en todo el
territorio y la cerveza se prohibió en
el año 1989 vamos que me imagino que con
estos datos mucha gente no pisará
islandia en su vida pero además de todo
esto islandia tiene una gran cualidad y
es que es un país muy rico y aquí viene
la pregunta que seguro que muchos os
estaréis haciendo
[Música]
como han podido ser tan ricos siendo tan
aislados pues eso vamos a responder lo
más adelante porque lo cierto es que
aunque estén tan aislados como ya os
hemos dicho eso de los países más ricos
y más modernos del mundo en términos de
pib per cápita los irlandeses son más
ricos incluso que los singapurenses los
estadounidenses o incluso los daneses
además este país cuenta con una
distribución de la riqueza envidiable y
es el sexto país con el índice de
desarrollo humano más alto del planeta
sin embargo si islandia es famosa por
algo es por la crisis financiera
podríamos decir que fue el país más
afectado por la crisis de 2008 y os
preguntaréis pero cómo es posible que un
país que esté tan aislado puede estar
tan afectado por una crisis
internacional y lo que es más importante
que hicieron para salir de esta crisis y
continuar creciendo a ritmos de más del
4% anual pues atentos islandia la
exitosa fórmula del país que no rescató
a sus bancos pero salvó su economía así
es este país no rescató a sus bancos de
hecho esta es una de las razones por las
que durante mucho tiempo islandia era el
súper modelo de la izquierda
anticapitalista algo así como un bastión
contra el neoliberalismo
como vais a ver en este vídeo la
historia no es tan simple es más no se
parece en nada a la narrativa que
intentaron vender desde muchos medios de
comunicación y por eso la pregunta que
hoy nos hacemos es porque islandia es
tan rica y como salieron de la crisis
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes antes os tengo que recomendar
un nuevo canal de youtube en el que
colabora visual político
hablamos de si lo hubiera sabido el
nuevo canal de actualidad financiera
creado por mutuactivos en este canal
vais a descubrir todas las tendencias
más importantes que mueven las finanzas
internacionales puede ser rentable
invertir en empresas sostenibles cómo
podemos usar la bolsa para proteger
nuestros ahorros de la inflación cómo se
está comportando el mercado de valores
en la salida de la pandemia todas estas
son preguntas a las que se responden en
este canal todo ello por supuesto sin
kilbane sin sensacionalismo y con
muchísimo muchísimo rigor os dejo el
link en la descripción y ahora sí vamos
a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
y la liberación del pulpo durante
décadas la economía islandesa estuvo
controlada por el llamado pulpo y diréis
que pulpo nos referimos pues no no nos
referimos al animal el pulpo es como se
conoce en islandia a las 14 familias que
controlaron toda la economía y la
política del país hasta finales del
siglo 20 para que os hagáis una idea
incluso los suministros de la base que
tiene la otan en este país estaban
controlados por una de estas familias
por aquel entonces la principal
industria islandesa era la pesca y como
os podéis imaginar todo este sector
estaba controlado bien por empresas
estatales dirigidas por miembros del
pulpo o bien por empresas privadas
propiedad de algún miembro del cuerpo
como os podéis imaginar también estaban
art y subvencionadas por el gobierno sin
embargo todo esto cambió con la llegada
al poder de éste
este señor que veis en pantalla es nada
más y nada menos que david oddsson
primer ministro de islandia entre 1991 y
el señor ozone es el responsable de la
privatización de todo el sector pesquero
y las grandes bajadas de impuestos bajo
su gobierno el impuesto de sociedades-
en islandia pasó del 48% al 18% también
eliminado prácticamente todos los
subsidios a sectores no productivos e
hizo todo lo posible por diversificar la
economía de islandia tan sólo tres años
más tarde de que otros son llegar al
gobierno en el año 1944 islandia ya
entraba en el espacio económico europeo
y así es como comenzó el milagro
económico islandés
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea desde el año
2003 hasta 2008 este país que tiene una
media anual del 6 4% estas cifras son
propias de un país emergente pero ella
se lo que estaréis pensando de verdad
bastó con liberalizar la economía para
que islandia de repente se convirtiera
en un oasis de progreso pues aquí llega
la cara b
realización financiera provocó que
islandia se convirtiera de un día para
otro en un paraíso para la inversión
extranjera las medidas de hoy son
lograron dar confianza al mercado
internacional para que los bancos de
islandia tuvieran muchísimo poder
pasando de ser un país pesquero
convencional a convertirse en todo un
monstruo financiero y grace que programa
hay en darle tanto poder los bancos y
como os podéis imaginar la respuesta a
esta pregunta es que cuando los bancos
colapsan se desata una crisis de
proporciones nacho vidal ianas atentos
el colapso del sistema financiero
islandés se acelera y diréis pero porque
qué ocurrió para que se produjera todo
este colapso pues atentos
[Música]
el país que dijo no a los rescates en el
año 2007 islandia era el sexto país más
rico de todo el planeta sin embargo un
año más tarde tuvieron que pedir ayuda
al fondo monetario internacional
[Música]
como llegaron a este extremo tan rápido
pues todo empezó porque en pocos años
pasaron de ser un país conocido por la
pesca las plantas hidroeléctricas y los
volcanes a ser todo un centro financiero
para que os hagáis una idea en el año
2008 una familia promedio islandesa era
tres veces más rica que en el año 2003 y
pese a no tener mcdonald's islandia
tiene la mayor concentración de campos
de golf per cápita del mundo y diréis
pero que había detrás de todo ese
crecimiento pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
en el año 2008 los tres principales
bancos de islandia ni de valor en
activos casi 11 veces el pib del país
eso es como si jaypee morgan bank of
america y wells fargo tuvieran 33 veces
más tamaño de lo que tienen hoy en día
estos bancos comenzaron a atraer
inversiones de todo el mundo primero por
la alta calificación del país y segundo
por las altas tasas de interés que sus
bancos pagaban a los inversores todo
este dinero se utilizaba principalmente
para prestar y hacer inversiones en
otros países europeos vamos que islandia
se convirtió en una especie de macro
fondo de inversión conclusión en el año
2008 esos bancos islandeses tenían una
deuda ocho veces mayor que todo el país
mientras todas las inversiones que
habían en el resto de europa daban
retornos no había ningún problema de
hecho entre el año 2003 y el año 2008 la
corona islandesa duplicó su valor es
decir que no solamente los islandeses
ganaban más dinero sino que además ese
dinero cada vez valía más pero no sólo
eso como los bancos islandeses se
recibían dinero de todo el mundo los
ciudadanos irlandeses también conseguían
créditos con más facilidad de hecho lo
normal por estos lares era refinanciar
las deudas hasta bien
y así es como islandia un país con la
población de murcia se convirtió en un
sistema financiero atado a una nación y
os preguntaréis pero qué pasó para que
todo este sistema colapsara cuál fue el
punto de inflexión pues creo que ya os
lo podéis imaginar
wall street cae tras la quiebra de
lehman brothers y la venta de merrill
lynch exacto en el año 2008 estalló la
crisis financiera en todo el mundo y
esto tuvo consecuencias bestiales para
islandia la quiebra de los bancos desató
un pánico en los mercados y por supuesto
los bancos europeos dejaron de prestar
dinero a los bancos islandeses todo esto
significa que los bancos islandeses
tuvieron que subir la tasa de interés
hasta el 15,5 por ciento para evitar la
fuga de capitales pero esto no sirvió de
nada porque el banco central sólo
controlaba una pequeña parte de lo que
se prestaba debido a la crisis los
activos de los bancos que llegaron a
valer 11 veces el pib de islandia ya
valían muchísimo menos pero las deudas
que valían 8 veces el pib de todo el
país ya no se podían refinanciar es
decir los bancos islandeses tenían que
pagar un montón de dinero mucho más de
todo el dinero que tenía el país y eso
se unía islandia en la bancarrota más
absoluta
[Música]
pero aquí no termina la historia porque
como los bancos tenían que devolver los
préstamos que hacían liquidaban sus
activos en la divisa islandesa es decir
la corona islandesa y esto que provocó
pues que esta salida masiva de capitales
hizo que el precio de la corona se
hundiera dicho de otra forma que sólo
tres días todo el sector bancario
islandés colapsó y ahí es cuando el
gobierno tuvo que pedir un préstamo al
fondo monetario internacional-
[Música]
y os preguntaréis pero con tantos
problemas y con toda europa echando mano
de ellos porque no querían integrarse en
la unión europea pues de hecho islandia
presentó una solicitud para unirse la
unión europea en el año 2009 sin embargo
a finales del año 2012 islandia ya se
había recuperado de la crisis la divisa
irlandesa también se había recuperado
así que los islandeses se pensaron dos
veces eso de entrar en el euro y en la
unión europea pero ya sé lo que os
preguntaréis ahora bien todo esto está
fantástico pero como pudieron salir de
la crisis de esa forma tan milagrosa
seguramente muchos creáis que sabéis la
respuesta y esto es así porque durante
mucho tiempo el caso islandés y eno
portadas de periódicos con titulares
como éste
islandia el éxito de dejar caer a la
banca y no salvarla con el dinero del
contribuyente habéis oído bien islandia
se convirtió en todo un símbolo de la
lucha contra los malvados bancos que
provocaron la crisis sí es cierto que
islandia fue uno de los pocos países que
no rescató a sus bancos ahora bien la
historia es muy distinta a la leyenda
recordáis que antes hemos dicho que
islandia pidió un préstamo al fondo
monetariointernacional hablamos de un
préstamo de más de dos mil millones de
dólares y diréis para qué servía todo
ese dinero pues precisamente para
garantizar los depósitos que los
ahorradores islandeses tenían en los
bancos básicamente el gobierno de
islandia nacional hizo a sus tres
principales bancos con el dinero del fmi
y de otros bancos centrales por supuesto
la mayor parte de ese dinero que habían
puesto los inversores internacionales se
perdió pero no es del todo correcto
decir que islandia dejó caer a sus
bancos y desde luego no es para nada
correcto decir que islandia se saltará
un milímetro la ortodoxia económica al
contrario
en el año 2015 islandia ya había
liquidado prácticamente todas las deudas
que tenía con el fm y la nacionalización
de la banca fue una medida de emergencia
es decir algo que se puso en marcha
única y exclusivamente para evitar que
los ahorradores perdieran dinero de
hecho en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo islandia ha terminado de
resolver todos los problemas financieros
y por eso en este año 2021 nos
encontramos con noticias como esta
islandia lanza la privatización del
banco estatal island banksy y ya se lo
que se estaría preguntando en este
momento pero de dónde sacaron todo el
dinero para poder devolver los préstamos
cómo fueron capaces de salir de la
crisis de una forma tan milagrosa pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
canción de hielo y fuego si hay algo que
ha hecho a islandia archiconocida en
todo el mundo es juego de tronos como
seguramente sabréis muchos islandia fue
el escenario de muchísimas escenas de
esta serie pues bien el hecho de que
esta serie se grabará en islandia tiene
mucho que ver con nuestra historia
[Música]
básicamente tras el cataclismo de 2008
los islandeses se dieron cuenta de que
sólo había una forma de salir adelante y
no no tenían nada que ver con la
ingeniería financiera ni con el
maquillaje de las cuentas públicas creo
que esto podría ser alguna buena
elección para algún país que yo me sé la
única solución para volver a ser ricos
es creando riqueza y permitiendo que
surjan nuevos sectores económicos y
diréis qué ventajas tiene islandia que
no tengan otros lugares pues entre otras
muchas cosas islandia de un paisaje
único en el mundo casi parece de otro
planeta y esto es una oportunidad única
para hacer negocios como este
como islandia se convirtió en el
escenario perfecto para las películas de
ciencia ficción de hollywood habéis oído
bien desde el año 2008 o islandia se ha
convertido en el escenario de las
superproducciones de hollywood desde los
paseos de jon snow juego de tronos hasta
varias escenas de las últimas películas
de star wars el cine se ha convertido en
algo tan importante en este país que en
el año 2018 se han llegado a abrir
enormes estudios de grabación pero no
sólo eso de que otras maneras se puede
monetizar un paisaje tan único en el
mundo pues atentos el turismo continúa
siendo el principal motor de crecimiento
el 47% de los nuevos trabajos creados en
los últimos 12 meses viene del turismo
seguro que muchos de vosotros habréis
visitado islandia en los últimos años y
si no seguro que tendréis algún amigo
que lo ha hecho y no es casualidad hasta
los años 2000 sólo algunos mochileros se
atrevían con este país pero desde el año
2009 el turismo en islandia se ha
disparado atentos a esta gráfica
y aquí podéis ver cómo el turismo e
islandia ha despegado tras la crisis de
2008 de hecho antes de la pandemia del
coronavirus islandia llegó a superar los
2 millones de turistas al año eso es
casi 5 veces la población total del país
ella sé lo que estaréis pensando cómo
han reaccionado al coronavirus a fin de
cuentas si hay una industria castigada
por la pandemia esa es sin duda alguna
el turismo pues lo cierto es que
islandia está explotando muchas otras
cosas aparte de su paisaje veréis al
devaluarse la moneda local los bienes y
servicios islandeses se hicieron más
baratos para los extranjeros
principalmente uno el aluminio atentos a
esta otra gráfica
como podéis ver islandia no ha perdido
el tiempo tan pronto como estalló la
crisis el país se puso a exportar
aluminio como si no hubiera mañana este
país puede ser casi un microestado pero
ahora mismo está entre los 10
productores de aluminio del mundo cada
año exportan unas 840 mil toneladas de
aluminio y por supuesto a todo esto hay
que sumarle otra exportación típicamente
islandesa el pescado de nuevo hablamos
de otro sector que se ha disparado tras
la crisis del año 2008 y pensando bien
sólo con el turismo la pesca y el
aluminio islandia podría haber salido
muy bien parada de la crisis a fin de
cuentas nuestros tres sectores se
caracterizan por dar trabajo a muchísima
gente todo esto por si mismo serviría
para explicar como islandia atajó todos
los problemas de desempleo derivados por
la crisis pero lo cierto es que la
economía de este país es toda una caja
de sorpresas
[Música]
como islandia se convirtió en un paraíso
de los mineros de bitcoin si seguís
visual por tyc desde hace tiempo
seguramente ya conoceréis esta historia
con todos los detalles porque pues
porque hemos hablado de ella hace poco
en un vídeo que os dejo la descripción
pero lo cierto es que el sector
tecnológico en islandia va mucho más
allá de las criptas divisas veréis si un
día queréis montar un servidor en
internet un centro de datos hay una cosa
muy importante que vais a necesitar
energía energía para poder refrigerar
todos los miles de discos duros que
están en funcionamiento las 24 horas del
día
[Música]
pues bien en este respecto islandia
ofrece un aspecto fundamental energía
verde y absurdamente barata como sabéis
casi toda la energía en este país viene
de la hiperactividad térmica que tiene
la isla recordad que está entre dos
fallas gigantescas y que es una isla
volcánica así que los islandeses
disfrutan de una factura de la luz muy
pero que muy barata y eso ha disparado
toda clase de empresas muy pero que muy
tecnológicas que decís que no conocéis
ninguna empresa tecnológica en islandia
pues atentos el monumento web eonline de
islandia homenaje a los jugadores
inmortalizando sus nombres habéis oído
bien pues alguno no lo conoce el eve
online es uno de los juegos online más
complejos que existen es algo así como
una especie del mundo paralelo de
ciencia ficción que tienen más de 300
mil personas que juegan a él todos los
meses y podríamos decir que existe toda
una subcultura en torno al ebro online
de hecho es un juego que parece hecho
para los fanáticos de la política como
vosotros así que no me extrañaría que
muchos de los que estáis viendo este
vídeo seáis auténticos fans de este
juego me lo podéis dejar en los
comentarios es apetece pues bien la
empresa detrás de este juego nación
islandia y tiene sus principales
estudios en reikiavik dicho de otra
forma que para ser un país tan pequeño
existe un sector tecnológico nada
desdeñable y todo esto explica por qué
en los últimos años islandia no
solamente es un país rico es que además
ha seguido creciendo a ritmos de más del
4% interanual pero ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros de verdad queréis que
islandia va a ser capaz de mantener todo
este crecimiento o volveremos a ver otra
crisis en este país podrán remontar el
sector turístico tras el coronavirus
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto recordad
visitar si lo hubiera sabido el nuevo
canal de finanzas en el que colabora
visual político y como siempre no
olvidéis que aquí en este canal sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a visual político y dadle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones les ha gustado
este vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en
el próximo 1 y hasta pronto
[Música]